of the victories are coming the hot and
Furious and Christian you you're with
guests Rochelle a victory a good result
but more importantly a very
aesthetically pleasing game as well you
must be feeling quite proud right yeah I
am tell us about the opening phase the
middle game where do you feel like
you're taking over the initiative after
she played F5 and I took on F5 I was not
really expecting her to play Knife six I
thought the idea of Queen E8 was killed
Knight B6 and like go Knight A4 or
something okay so
um and I thought this way she takes on
F5 with the bishop and uh I don't know I
just thought this is her plan so Knight
F6 took me by surprise do you know Iris
have you ever played again sir
so it was a new opponent did you do some
preparation before the tournament Joel
was mentioning that he preferred against
all his opponents before the tournament
did you get any prep
um I didn't
honestly I needed a break from chess
before this tournament
so um no I didn't I didn't really know
who was playing until yesterday is it
about motivation well what is about that
you made that break I was just like
playing
extremely bad in my last three
tournaments like I
um I withdrew from all of them because I
just like
I just didn't feel very motivated yet
but this is definitely a good game to
get that motivation back uh and you
found and we were all quite impressed
with this move G3 just a simple move
that completely kills her whole game
because she cannot take on F5 anymore
um and this was the move that you must
have felt quite good about just giving
up the exchange getting the Knight on E6
definitely taking over and finished it
off in style after that Rochelle uh
you've participated in this event quite
a few times you've never won it what is
your ambition for answering you want to
win it finally this year I mean I'm kind
of just taking it game by game like I'm
definitely giving myself like zero
pressure because
um this isn't my first year playing and
I still have a few years after this so
it's like I don't think it's the biggest
of deals if I don't perform Super well
so I just want to have a good time
excellent guys any questions so Rochelle
congratulations on your first round of
Victory what if spectacular game we
really love the 94 move and I have a
question how do you usually start your
tournaments do you because we talked
about other players who maybe start off
badly losing the first game do you
usually win your first round or do you
have troubles with first rounds
um it honestly depends like if it's an
open tournament
um if I'm playing down
first round then I typically
I think I typically win but like
sometimes you know there's hiccups
um
I usually I think I usually have pretty
decent first rounds
good that's good for you just
congratulations and keep up the good
work thank you absolutely
for the girls uh the the results are
coming in uh hot and heavy we have four
out of five results already uh one draw
wow so only Yen draw against Atwell and
then we have three wins Lee against
Persona against